hallo mein name ist luca und bespielen
heute ein spiel mit schafen dieses spiel
heißt wenn zwei weil das teil 2 ist
würde ich mal grob sagen in dem spiel
geht es darum dass wir einen schaf
namens wenn sind und das schafften
urteil weist immer wissen wollte wie es
dann aussieht das ist wenn das schwarze
schaf hier hier können hier im menü auf
hilfe klicken da steht alles erst wieder
da es wenn das potenteste wirtschaft die
sind da noch die ganzen sachen erklärt
die haben mit gegner extras unter extras
ich war es gibt verschiedene extras
sogar aber wir kennen uns ja das war
eine kluge aussage dass wir uns kennen
wir klicken einfach mal auf start und
werden erst mal die anleitung spielen
wir sind diese scharf in die mitte
können ganz normal rumlaufen und das
sind schafe die hier alles klar können
wir irgendwie hier zum wasser laufen
oder sowas
als ob das so portale sind tatsache dass
wir quasi einfach machen müssen ist uns
von hinten an die schafe heranschleichen
und dann einfach
er ist das ziel des spiels soll dann im
märz wird das letzte schafe mit ok ok es
wären ok übertreibt mal wieder ist in
ordnung ich hab sonnenstrahlen am und so
unser level bonus ist level 1 geschafft
nun mal ein blablabla egal wir drücken
der taste und jetzt was ist das denn
hier für einer ist es was ist wenn wir
den rein theoretisch mal können wir den
auch irgendwie hallo habe ich dann auch
irgendwie von hinten an machen kann
[Musik]
ich habe im leben verloren aber egal wir
sind werden wir sind nicht hier um lang
zu schnacken sondern wir werden direkt
kleine schaf babys machen und jetzt ganz
schnell ganz schnell in den bann
kann ich vielleicht noch den bis dahin
und direkt mitgenommen dann nehmen wir
hier direkt den kollegen hier noch mal
eben dann gehen wir hier an sie noch mal
eben schnell ran so bamm bamm bamm bamm
bamm
und jetzt kommt nämlich auch schon
wieder dieser blöde an hat sich auch
durch geht doch kompletter unser
punktekonto fühlt sich aber schon 683
punkte übrigens packt euch nicht wenn
man extra eine flasche was das was
bringt das jetzt freunde einer rakete
eine rakete eine rakete das was bringt
mir das jetzt bin ich jetzt doppelt so
schnell oder was kommt wenn
das geht was geht das wenn es viel
schneller geworden wo ein hund ist mir
auf den fersen und der typ dahin aber ja
ja sie haben es geschafft ohne dass ich
noch ewig getötet wurde wir sind gut in
dem spiel freundin wir schaffen das ja
wir übrigens falls ihr euch fragt wieso
die grafik so scheiße ist das liegt am
spiel das spiel ist gefühlt 1804
entwickelt worden alles klar macht ruhig
noch mehr schafe dahin aber es ist in
ordnung wir sind ja so einen ganz
schönen rasanter sven de nuke das
natürlich gar nicht mehr geht hier alle
stellungen direkt durch mit den schafen
übrigens nicht auf eine wiese stellen
und dann auch und sonne
wer vielleicht nicht so toll alles klar
auf einmal kommt ein ufo hatte diese
schafe mediathek kann darüber sind immer
so übel ist schwer dass man die
irgendwie mal fertig kriegen kann hier
kommt sie durch zieht euch die durch
nein ich habe im leben doch jetzt
schnappte hier da vorne noch das nein
das getränk gor wird gegangen auch da
schon was nächstes fest gar nicht was
diese sachen bedeuten ich habe gerade
irgendetwas komisches bei mir im kopf
aber ich weiß nicht was das heißt aber
warte ich jetzt schon wieder das nächste
level geht ja wir sind mittlerweile so
weit dass ein ufo am start ist der
wärter von den der hirte von den ziegen
ein rund haben wir am start wir haben da
oben noch ein kleines mädchen die die
ganze zeit darum neue und wir haben auch
immer noch fan der sich hier durch die
massen boomt und jetzt gleich von einem
hund wahrscheinlich attackiert wird an
einer kommt das mittel nein mann sven
konzentriert sich jetzt auf die
wichtigen dinge im leben hier die müssen
dass die schafe nicht sterben hier soll
jetzt schön teleportiert geben die
sachen sammeln hier direkt den nächsten
mitnehmen stelle ist wenn da kommt ja
unter uns
schnell zwei schafe bevor dieses mädel
da hinkommt kontron kontron com sven
komplett das geschenk mitnehmen und
jetzt hier das letztliche abkommens wenn
kommt wenn wir's 999 ja wenn das nächste
level geschafft glückwunsch episode an
einleitungen geschafft ok perfekt wenn
killer 69 lance mackey 69 kann keine
zahl angeben haben das weiß auch ein
bisschen isis spielen jetzt einfach mal
wie sie zwar auf gott was ist denn hier
los auf dieser landschaft und das sind
alles nur so welche die die ganze zeit
sondern extra einladung brauchen damit
das ganze bei denen mal klappt was ist
denn das hier für ein spiel bitten ein
hund und und und und und und und und und
und und lass mich in ruhe okay und
wieder war jetzt kommt es irgend geht
dahin haben wir haben hier schon wieder
ein neues jahr
wenn du bist der geilste schnell da
kommt der hund mainz werden rund und und
welche schnell wächst renz fenstern ich
glaube nach diesem spiel haben dieses
das ist das schwarze schaf ich glaube
dass kam nach die wieviel wegen zum
handy
definitiv kam es danach luca okay das
setzte schaaf das letzte scharf so
schnell schlecht werden schnell darum
kommt der ziegen wir wir haben das level
geschafft meine freunde ja hat er das
ist doch nicht war als ob das jetzt
einfach nur noch das macht einfach
keinen spaß natürlich will man immer so
ein bisschen erreichen dass man
irgendwie das ganze schafft und es sind
auch echt tatsächlich wertvoll animierte
zwischenszenen aber das ganze spiel ist
einfach zeichentrick und total absurd es
jetzt noch mal eben was passiert wenn es
mich töten lassen also ich bin jetzt
hier gerade im kampf mit dem hund und
jetzt hab ich nur noch ein leben in gehe
ich jetzt mal eben hier zum ziegen wir
ca
wenn ich mich vielleicht tomb raider
hallo
willst du mich vielleicht hier irgendwie
kann sein dass die ziegen wird überhaupt
nichts gegen mich mal freunde das schaf
ist in die rot geworden was was geht mit
dem schaf das ist ja übels crazy schaut
euch das mal anders das game over
freunde das war es mit diesem spiel ist
wenn das 68 prozent gefallen natürlich
mich über eine bewertung freue ich hoffe
es ging klar irgendwie mit der grafik
oder so weil das spiel ist halt einfach
sauer
sonst würde ich sagen sehen uns in einem
nächsten video wieder habt oder idee
abonniert mich einfach